please welcome dan hello
hi drew hi dan how you doing
i'm doing well it is so good to be back
it is
so wonderful to see you again and our
last segment that we did together
was air fryer oriented and we're about
to hit
that thing again we just love air fryers
it's just our thing
it's also like a healthier way to cook
you can do a lot of
crusting and breading without so much
oil
and you can also make fish which is what
we did last time
you know our last book air fryer
perfection we had you know we had steaks
and
fish and a huge range of stuff in there
obviously vegetables crispy brussels
sprouts
and the new one there's gonna be 75 new
recipes that are healthy focused
um and we're doing i want to show you
one today that isn't even a finished
recipe this is
totally in process to kind of help
show behind the curtain what what what
we actually do here at america's test
kitchen
tell us dan what are we making so we are
making a really hearty
amazing lentil and mushroom burger um
you know it's it really lives up to the
burger name this isn't kind of like
oh it's technically a burger it's in a
patty this is rich
it's got that kind of nice meaty texture
to it it's super savory
and there's a lot of cool test kitchen
tricks involved in pulling this off
um should we should we make them dan i
am your student
teach me all right so
we have in a bowl here so i've done a
little bit of work ahead of time we've
got some cremini mushrooms which are
super savory
we've got cashews which is a totally
unusual ingredient in a veggie burger
but they had tons of richness
and some good fattiness to it we've also
got some shallot and
celery so we food processed that up so
you get that nice nubby texture you know
you want a burger to have some of that
and that's what we make sure we have
here a little bit of burger in there as
well and so what we're going to do is
add to that some cooked lentils those
add some nice creaminess and richness as
well we've also got a little bit of
panko
and so what panko bread crumbs are going
to do is bind up moisture it's going to
keep the burgers
you know holding together really really
nicely any excess moisture will get
bound up in that
and then finally we've got a little bit
of mayonnaise now mayonnaise is an
emulsion it's really creamy and rich
it's going to obviously add some fat but
it's going to help bind it together and
add richness kind of throughout
dan this mixture before i put the
lentils panko
mayonnaise folded in did you put it in a
microwave
at first and why do you guys microwave
absolutely so we really like doing as
much as we possibly can an air fryer
right you're going to use the airfryer
let's not get a skillet out let's not do
all that so we do use a microwave so we
food processed those ingredients up
until
uh they're broken down to a nice texture
add a little bit of water a little bit
of vulgar and microwave it's just about
six minutes
and that helps cook everything through
and and help this
helps it absorb a lot of the moisture
and the lentils
how do you prepare those to get them
ready to fold in
so the cool thing you you can obviously
cook lentils for this but one of the
cool things is it works
really great with a can of lentils which
a lot of people don't think about they
buy canned beans all the time but canned
lentils are great
and so it's just a whole can of lentils
okay okay so you've got a little bit of
water there we're gonna form these into
patties and they're a little bit sticky
so getting your hands a little bit wet
will help with that i don't have any oh
yes i do
we're going to make patties that are
about a half a cup each now
the next step before putting an air
fryer is you want to spray with
vegetable oil spray
in the basket we're not going to have to
flip these burgers which is amazing you
know in a skillet you can flip them and
you can break them
really really easy to not have to flip
them but they want the one step is you
definitely want to spray
with some vegetable oil spray on the
bottom and i'm going to fit a couple in
mind i think you can fit a few more in
yours so
you know you just want to space them out
have a little bit of breathing room
between them but as many as you can put
in your air fryer is great
and what's wonderful about the air fryer
you know it cooks from all angles and
we're going to get
wonderful browning all over so we tested
this recipe you know dozens and dozens
of times it's not finished yet it's
still in process
but we got it to a point where it gets
really nice and brown and so we're gonna
go into the airfryer
we're gonna cook at 400 degrees for
anywhere from 10 to 15 minutes
and then we're gonna pull out our cooked
ones from the airfryer which looks
gorgeous dan gorgeous exactly and so
yours are super browned and then if you
want cheese on them you pop that on
them back in for another minute and you
can see it's beautifully melted on there
yeah i'm going with the cheese dan um
because well it's been a week
it's been a week yeah so i've got the
the mayonnaise the mustard the ketchup i
really love that
i'm gonna go with a little tomato as
well
i think you've got some american cheese
on yours which is like my favorite
burger cheese it's like a perfect
melting cheese
um let's give this a shot you ready dan
cheers yes
cheers
the texture is fantastic i love that it
has
the texture of a burger right it's
really really moist it's
you know it's what you want out of a
burger but
there's so much more going on this is
like
as good as it gets it's good i'm good
and then you have the pinto and bean
and beet burger the southwestern black
bean burger the ultimate veggie burger
dan i oh spiced cauliflower burger with
yogurt sauce
oh i want to try that one too drew th
this
this recipe here because it's not
finished we're still sending it out to
like our army of home
testers uh in america's test kitchen and
i think you're gonna
help us out with that is that right i'm
really excited actually because our
viewers are going to be able to become
home testers too
so guess what we're putting america's
test kitchen survey
onto our website so that people can make
these burgers
and give their feedback and you guys
will help decide
whether or not this recipe lands in
the next america's test kitchen cookbook
so head to the drewberrymore show.com
atk survey to participate and that's not
all i'm really excited to announce
that you can now get actually your hands
on this very air fryer and this
is in our launch color which is the sage
green
from the beautiful collection of
kitchenware
that i designed and creative it's
exclusively on walmart.com right now
the whole line is coming to walmart
doors
april 19th but i want to send
every single vff one of these
and i just want to say happy st
patrick's day with our sage green air
[Applause]
[Music]
fryers
you